Robert for the writers that submit their
scripts to crowd source studios what's
in it for them the competition mm-hmm
same thing as it's for directors and
actors and so forth
it's exposure just like most screenplay
competitions they say we're gonna but
what we do differently are two things
one is we're gonna probably make the
movie you know if we pick if you win
this script script competition why yeah
we're gonna make your movie a B we are
giving gross points to the writers the
actors and the director first dollar
gross not back in not net none of that
stuff there's no saying in Hollywood the
most creative people in Hollywood are
the accountants and so you know net
points you're never gonna see them so um
yeah we're giving first-dollar gross
you